you had by the way
i should say a excellent conversation
when uh donald hoffman
yeah he's interesting is there any
inkling
of his sense in your mind that reality
is uh
very far from actual like objective
reality is very far from
the kind of reality we imagine we
perceive and we
play with in our human minds well
the first thing to grant is that
there we are never in direct contact
with reality whatever it is unless that
reality is consciousness right so
we we're only ever experiencing
consciousness and its contents
and then the question is how does that
circumstance relate to quote reality at
large
and donald hoffman is somebody who's
happy to speculate well maybe there
isn't a reality at large maybe it's all
just
consciousness on some level and that
that's interesting
that runs into to my eye
various philosophical problems
that or at least you have to do a lot
you have to add to that
uh picture i mean that you know a
picture of idealism for i mean that's
usually
all the all the whole family of views
that would just say that
the universe is just mind or just
consciousness at bottom you know we'll
go by the name of idealism in
western philosophy
you have to add to that idealistic
picture all kinds of
epic cycles and kind of weird
coincidences
and to get the
to get the predictability of our
experience and the success of
of materialist science to make sense in
that context
right so the fact that we can what does
it mean to say
that there's only consciousness at
bottom
right nothing outside of consciousness
because no one's ever experienced
anything outside of consciousness
there's no scientist has ever done an
experiment
where they were contemplating data
no matter how far removed from our sense
bases you know whether it's they're
looking at the
hubble deep field or they're they're
smashing atoms or whatever that whatever
tools they're using
they're still just experiencing
consciousness and it's
various deliverances and
layering their concepts on top of that
so
that's always true and yet that somehow
doesn't seem to capture
the the character of our
continually discovering that our
materialist assumptions
are are confirmable right so you take
take the fact that we
we unleash this fantastic amount of
energy from within
an atom right you know we first we have
the theoretical
suggestion that it's possible right we
need to come back to einstein there's a
lot of energy
in that matter right and what if we
could release
it right and then we perform an
experiment at
in this case you know the trinity test
site in new mexico
where the people who are most adequate
to this conversation people like
robert oppenheimer
are standing around not all together
certain it's going to work
right they're performing an experiment
they're wondering what's going to happen
they're wondering if their calculations
around the yield are off by orders of
magnitude some of them are still
wondering whether the the entire
atmosphere of earth is going to
get kind of combust right that the
the the the the nuclear chain reaction
is not going to stop
and lo and behold
there was that energy to be released
free from within the nucleus of an atom
and that could so
it's it's just what
the picture one forms from those kinds
of experiments and just the knowledge is
just our understanding of evolution just
the fact that
the the earth is billions of years old
and life is hundreds of millions of
years old and we weren't here
to think about any of those things um
and all of those processes were
happening therefore in the dark
and they are the processes that allowed
us to to emerge
you know from prior life forms in the
first place
to say that it's all amazing that
nothing exists
outside of consciousness conscious minds
of the sort that we
experience it just seems um
it seems like a bizarrely
anthropocentric claim
uh you know analogous to
you know the moon isn't there if you're
not if no one's looking at it right
the moon as a moon isn't there if no
one's looking at it i'll grant that
because
that's already a kind of fabrication
born of concepts but the idea that
there's nothing there
that there's no nothing that corresponds
to what we experience as the moon
unless someone's looking at it that just
seems
just a way too parochial way to set out
on this journey of
discovery there is something there
there's a computer waiting to render the
moon when you look at it
the capacity for the moon to exist is
there so
if if we're indeed living in a
simulation
which i find a compelling thought
experiment uh it's possible that there
is a kind of
rendering mechanism but not in a silly
way that we think about in video games
but in some kind of more fundamental
physics way and we have to
account for the fact that it renders
experiences that no one has had yet
that no one has any expectation of
having
it can violate the expectations of
everyone lawfully right and then there's
some lawful understanding of how why
that's so
it's like um i'm just to bring it back
to mathematics
like certain numbers are prime whether
we have discovered them or not right
like
there's there's the highest prime number
that anyone can
name now and then there's the next prime
number that no one can name
and it's there right so it's like it's
it's to say that
our minds are putting it there that what
we know as mind
in ourselves is in some way in some
sense putting it there
that like that that the base layer of
reality is consciousness
right you know that we're we're
identical to the thing that is rendering
this this reality there's some
you know hubris is the wrong word but
it's like there's some it's like
it's okay if reality is bigger than what
we experience
you know and and it has structure that
we can't anticipate and that isn't just
um i mean
again there's a co there's there's
certainly a collaboration between our
minds
and whatever is out there to produce
what we call
you know the stuff you know of life but
um it's not the idea that
it's uh i don't know i mean there are
there
are a few stops on the train of idealism
and kind of new age
thinking and and eastern philosophy
that i don't philosophically i don't see
a need to take i mean the place
experientially and scientifically i feel
like it's it's
it you can get everything you want
acknowledging that consciousness has
a as a character that
can be explored from its own side so
that you're bringing kind of the first
person
experience back into the into the
conversation about you know what is a
human mind and you know
what is true and you can explore it with
with different degrees of rigor and
there are things to be discovered there
whether you're using a technique like
meditation or
psychedelics and that these experiences
have to be put in conversation
with what we understand about ourselves
from a third person side
neuroscientifically or in any other way
but to me the question is
what if reality the sense i have from
this kind of
you you play shooters no there's a
physics engine that generates that's
points
first person shooter games yes not often
but yes
i mean there's a physics engine that
generates consistent reality right
my sense is the same could be true for a
universe
in the following sense that our
conception of reality is we understand
it and now in the 21st century
is a tiny subset of the full reality
it's not that the reality
that we conceive of that's there the
moon being there is uh
not there somehow it's that it's a tiny
fraction what's
actually out there and so the uh the
physics engine
of the universe is just maintaining the
useful
physics the useful reality quote-unquote
uh for us to have a consistent
experience as human beings
but maybe we descendants of apes are
really only understand like 0.0001
of actual physics of reality like this
we can even just start with the
consciousness thing
but maybe our minds are just we're just
too dumb by design yeah i i
i that truly resonates with me and i'm
surprised it doesn't resonate more with
most
scientists that i talk to but when you
just look at
you look at how close we are
to chimps right and chimps don't know
anything right
clearly they have no idea what's going
on right and then you get us
but then you it's only a subset of human
beings
that really understand much of what
we're talking about on any you know in
any area of specialization
and if they all died in their sleep
tonight right you'd be left with people
who might take a thousand years
to rebuild the internet you know or if
ever
i mean literally it's like like you know
and you know i i would i would
extend this to myself i mean there there
are areas of scientific specialization
where i have either no
discernible competence i mean i've spent
no time on it i have not
acquired the tools it would just be an
article of faith for me to think that i
could acquire the tools to actually make
a breakthrough in those areas um
and i mean you know your own area is one
i mean you know
i i've never spent any significant
amount of time trying to be a
a programmer but
it's pretty obvious i'm not alan turing
right it's like like if if that were
if that were my capacity i would have
discovered that in in myself i would
i would have found programming
irresistible my few fault
my first fall starts in in learning
i think it was c um it was just
you know i bounced off it's like this
was not fun i hate i mean
trying to figure out what what you know
the syntax error that's causing this
thing not to compile
was just a [ __ ] awful experience i
hated it right i hated every minute
minute of it
so it was not um
so if it was just people like me left
like when do we get the internet again
right and we lose
we lose you know we lose the internet
when do we get it again right when do we
get a
anything like a proper science of
information
right you need a claude shannon or an
alan turing
just to plant a flag in the ground right
here and say all right can everyone see
this
even you don't quite know what i'm up to
you all have to come
over here to to make some progress um
and you know there are you know hundreds
of topics where that's the case
so we're bare we barely have a purchase
on making anything like discernible
intellectual progress in any generation
and yeah i'm
just a max tegmark makes this point he's
one of the few
people who does in physics
if you if you just to take the
the truth of evolution seriously right
and and
realize that there's nothing about us
that has evolved
to understand reality perfectly i mean
we just we're just not that kind of ape
right there's been no evolutionary
pressure along those lines so what we
are making do
with tools that were designed for
fights with sticks and rocks right
and it's amazing we could we can do as
much as we can we just you know that you
and i are just sitting here on
on the back of having received an mrna
vaccine
you know that uh is certainly changed
our life given what the last year was
like
like and it's going to change the world
if rumors of coming miracles are
are borne out i mean if it's now
seems likely we have a vaccine coming
for malaria
right which has been killing millions of
people a year
for as long as we've been alive um i
think it's down to like 800 000 people a
year
now because we've spread so many bed
nets around but
it was like two and a half million
people every year
uh it's amazing what we can do
but yeah i have if in fact the you know
the answer the book of nature
the back of the book of nature is you
understand
0.1 percent of what there is to
understand and half of what you think
you understand is wrong that would not
surprise me
at all it is funny to look at our
evolutionary history
even back to chimps i'm pretty sure even
chimps thought they end
under stood the world well so at every
point
in that timeline of evolutionary
development
throughout human history there's a sense
like
there's no more you hear this message
over and over there's no more things to
be invented
but a hundred years ago there were
there's a famous story i forget
which physicist told it but there was
there were
physicists telling their their
undergraduate students
not to go into to get graduate degrees
in physics because
basically all the problems have been
solved and this is like around 1915 or
so
you